hi there today we're gonna look at this
paper curiosity driven exploration by
self supervised prediction it's
relatively short idea so it shouldn't
take too long
so the fundamental idea of the paper is
to tackle the reward and the reward
sparseness problem reinforcement
learning for example if you have a Super
Mario game
like here and there is a number of ways
you can think of the reward but one way
you could formulate it is that you
simply get kind of a plus 1 reward when
you finish the game like or the level
let's say you finish the level you get
plus 1 if you die or don't make it in
time you get negative 1 I think there's
no way to not make it in oh yeah there's
actually there's a time limit so the the
problem here is that your algorithm kind
of needs to learn to make things now
such that it gets to the end of the
level but the reward is only at the end
of the level so basically step by step
it has no signal to go on because the
reward is always zero and it kind of
needs to learn these long-range
dependencies and that's notoriously hard
in reinforcement learning to step by
step learn actions that kind of maximize
some very long-term goal so you can also
think of a game of chess where your
reward is gonna be whether you win or
lose at the end but step by step if you
it's kind of this the reward is fiftyish
steps away so you have no way of kind of
step-by-step optimizing your actions in
a meaningful manner so the there are
many ways to get around this one way
that people have done is what's called
reward shaping and reward shaping is
you're trying to introduce additional
rewards kind of as a designer of the
algorithm that you know are kind of good
or helping to to solve the problem or at
least correlate it with
the reward you're gonna get at the end
so in Mario this could be like the
further right you go the more reward you
get you get kind of a an additional
reward if you go right coincidentally I
think in real Mario this also gives you
points but don't our situation is that
the reward is just gonna be at the end
you could also say like if you kill the
or if you if you stomp the the goombas
one going by you stomp that actually
gives you also a bit of reward in chess
you could say like the more pieces you
have that gives you a bit of reward if
you have more pieces than your opponent
if your opponent loses pieces and you
don't and you also get a bit of reward
if you get more territory on the board
and so on so these are all things that
we know kind of correlate with the end
reward like because in Mario for example
the the the end of the level is actually
on the right but of course it's not
perfect because sometimes there are
situations where he kind of have to go
go back go and go around something or go
over something and not immediately go to
the right as well as in chess there are
good sacrifices that you can make so
these these kind of additional rewards
they have help but they're not perfect
and the biggest problem with them is
they're very domain-specific so a
developer of the algorithm you basically
have to know the domain like Super Mario
and you have to know the goal is on the
right so you have to construct your
reward in order to reflect this and this
is this is a very domain-specific basic
you have to do it for every domain again
and again and again in chess you have to
know something about chess to play and
so on so one way around this and this
paper proposes one method to do this is
to introduce an additional reward not
based on the domain specifically but
based on what they call this curiosity
and it's specifically curiosity by self
supervised prediction so what does that
mean the idea is not new in that people
have kind of done
this before if we go for example down
here so here is this kind of doom
environment and what you could say is in
my agent I have kind of a little module
that's going to predict the future so
like if I'm if I'm here
then I will basically choose an action
my agent will choose an action like move
forward like press the forward key and
then I will predict how that's gonna
look and of course we know this kind of
a 3d environment so this probably gonna
be this part of the screen is gonna be
the full screen because you're now
closer and so on the perspective changed
a little bit but basically this is this
this review learned like a neural
network that predicts the future from
the state now and that action now and
basically the you could so you can train
this in a supervised fashion because you
will perform some actions you will
collect some data about this so you can
learn a network that is gonna predict
one step into the future basically how
the environment will look and then and
this is by no means kind of a new idea
to introduce rewards based on this type
of learning how the environment acts
we've seen this in like the a3 C paper
the original one where the additional
reward is something that pixel control
where they consider like okay this pixel
here
how much can I control it by my action
like how does my action influence it how
can I predict this and so on and to to
learn how to control the pixels on the
screen by your actions and to give a
reward based on that so that's that's
been around this idea and what this
paper here does specifically is they say
well I'm going to predict the future and
if I am wrong about the predict
then that gives me a reward and that's
that's the curiosity part basically it
means like if I have a good model of
what's gonna happen in the future and
then I predict the future and then I'm
wrong it means something new has
happened something special something
that I hadn't expected and therefore if
the goal is to get the algorithm to
explore by itself which is what you need
to do when you don't have a reward right
when you don't have a reward what you
want your algorithm to do is simply to
go around and explore and in in a sense
they're saying okay the way to do is is
to go by curiosity which means is to go
to actively seek out environments that
you haven't that you wouldn't expect
basically so it whenever you don't
expect something that means it's
something new that means you haven't had
this experience before right and that
means that it's kind of a new state to
explore that you haven't you've not seen
this before so kind of in absence of any
reward might as well go where you
haven't been before and that's that's
kind of the essence so they outline a
number of problems that you might have
with this approach they they give the
example let's first actually go to what
the the model actually looks like so
that's here you can see this is kind of
what they call an intrinsic curiosity
module so you have a state here you're
in a state you have your policy and your
policy gives you an action and the
action goes to an environment and the
environment gives you the next state and
also the what's called the reward and
they take all here ar e is the extrinsic
reward that you get from the environment
but they also combine this with in so
what's called an intrinsic reward that
you get from here
that you get from the curiosity module
and that's what we've discussed it kind
of tries to assess how new is the state
that I'm gonna be in how surprising it
is for me so the the thing is that I'm
gonna I'm going to first describe like a
at the model how you would build it and
how that gives gets you into problems
and then how to fix it so how you would
build this is to have this what's called
this forward model so the forward model
takes the action and the current state
and it kind of predicts the next state
that's in here don't worry about the Phi
hat right now it predicts the next state
and then you compare this to the what's
here to the actual next state you
subtract if you just look at the
difference between what you predict the
next states gonna be in what the next
state really is and that gives you the
intrinsic reward the the more different
these are the kind of higher the reward
that's what we've discussed like how how
much different is it from what I've
expected so how does that get into
problems and the authors gave a very
very good illustrative example of say
you are in an environment over here
you're in environment and you have your
screen right and here is kind of a road
that you need to maybe walk after and
here are some leaves in the wind I'm
very bad at drawing leaf so imagine
these are leaves and there's wind right
like winds coming from here and kind of
shaking up these leaves and so on so if
you simply try to predict this entire
screen from as your forward model what's
gonna happen is you will never be able
to predict how these leaves are gonna
move because they're basically you can't
influence them no no part of like you
can predict a bit from the current state
but
the action you take has no influence on
how these leaves are going to move
because they're influenced by the wind
and the wind is kind of this random ish
process that that you you can't control
so the the authors say because of this
your algorithm is always going to find
these leaves basically interesting
curious be curious about it because it
can't predict them and we've seen that
their reward that they model to give an
addition is based on how well you cannot
predict a certain state and they say
okay if if we do it like this then the
the kind of these things these random
things that we can't influence will
always be surprising and therefore we
will always be curious about them and
therefore we will always kind of look at
the leaves and be amazed and get reward
after reward because we can't predict
them that's not the goal so what what
they're arguing is that why are these
leaves not important for curiosity
because we can't influence them with our
actions like we can influence where we
go on this road because we can kind of
move and the road this kind of static
not governed by these random processes
but the leaves we we would like to
discard them
we can't influence them and therefore
what they say is what we need is an
encoder that takes a state and try to
delete this annotation so we need an
encoder here features that takes a state
and it outputs features of the state and
then we're not our forward model isn't
fed with the state it's fed with the
features of the state and it's not going
to output this the next state as such
but the features of the next state like
there it's predictive features and then
we're going to compare that with the
feed
of the true next state and that's what
we compare so how this is how does this
encoder these features need to look and
they're saying well these features
should kind of only consider things
about the state that are actually
dependent on our actions and they have a
I think a very interesting way of
achieving to train such an such an
encoder such a feature producing
function in that they say it's gonna be
a neural network that we train by this
training the so called inverse model so
we take this encoder and we train this
inverse model on top of it and the
inverse model takes the features of the
last state and the new state and is
trying to predict this action this
action right here so this is this action
the action we took to get from the old
state to the new state so this inverse
model is trained to predict what action
was taken to get from the old state to
the new state and by training the
encoder with this inverse model like
training this end-to-end you will make
the encoders such that it only considers
things that are actually relevant to
predicting this action so in the Leaves
example it would discard the leaves it
will discard anything that you can't
influence with your action and therefore
it will only retain features that are
dependent on your action I think that's
quite interesting way to get kind of rid
of the irrelevant information that they
don't want and then they can use this
encoder to train this forward model and
to essentially get this intrinsic reward
so I find this idea quite interesting
and as I said that the idea of intrinsic
reward and curiosity to go for
exploration is not new but I think this
is this kind of approach and I'm sure
it's been around in so
variance but I've just stumbled across
this and this is oh sorry this is quite
interesting cool so we're gonna take a
look and you can go about the math
yourself but they they do these kind of
experiments and they corrupt as you can
see part of the screen with noise here
and they of course show like okay since
the noise is not depending on our action
our features do actually discover this
noise only focus on the part that we can
actually influence prior actions so
that's I think all know pretty
interesting they show of course that
their algorithm then outperforms the
kind of baseline of a3 see on these
sparse reward tasks and the sparser here
you can see like the left is like dense
reward and then sparse reward and then
very sparse reward and at some point you
see the a3 see simply doesn't doesn't do
it anymore but what's also interesting
is here if the ICM in pixels which which
kind of means pixel based curiosity so
where we don't have this encoder where
we simply trying to predict the pixels
of the environment and that works if you
have like this kind of sparse reward
thing but if you want to if you have the
very sparse reward that also fails and
you actually need this design coder that
discards what's not relevant for
predicting the actions yeah so you can
even take a look at the rest of the
paper yourself I find I find it quite
interesting they analyze how their their
agent Explorer these mazes and things
and they have more experiments on like
benchmark tasks so have a look at it and
I'll see you next time